Новини дня «heute» з Мітрієм Зіріним.
Доброго вечора всім.
Найважливіші новини четверга у наступні 20 хвилин.
Новини спорту від Норберта Лемана.
- Добрий вечір.
Сьогодні у випуску:
Міністр економіки Габек оголошує «режим тривоги» -
у Німеччині стає все менше газу,
а ціна на нього зростає.
Історичне рішення в Брюсселі -
ЄС приймає рішення про надання Україні та Молдові
статусу кандидата на членство в ЄС.
Більше грошей для студентів -
Бундестаг ухвалив рішення
про підвищення стипендії
та розширення кола претендентів.
За словами міністра економіки Габека,
газова криза вже настала -
у відповідь на різке скорочення
поставок газу з Росії
Габек активує другий рівень аварійного плану
через ситуацію з газом.
Це було лише питання часу
і для багатьох не стало несподіванкою.
З березня діяв перший рівень (режим попередження),
кризовий штаб розпочав роботу.
Постачальники та великі споживачі змушені самостійно
закуповувати більше газу,
щоб якнайбільше заповнити газосховища.
Зараз в дію вступив другий рівень, «режим тривоги»:
він підвищує екстреність ситуації,
але поки що ніяк не впливає на споживачів.
Йде підготовка до активнішого використання
вугільних електростанцій
задля економії природного газу
під час виробництва електроенергії.
Якщо це не спрацює,
уряд Німеччини може запровадити
третій рівень - надзвичайний стан.
Тоді держава ухвалюватиме рішення
про квоти на постачання газу.
Перевага надаватиметься приватним домогосподарствам
та соціальним установам, як-от лікарням.
Клаус Бродбек з репортажем.
Це трапилось швидше, ніж очікували
та підкралося ближче, ніж сподівалися.
Міністр економіки в режимі кризи.
В Німеччині є перебої з газопостачанням.
Саме так це визначається.
Необхідно оголосити «режим тривоги».
Відтепер газ у Німеччині - дефіцитний товар.
Різкий спад постачання газу з Росії:
з 13 червня постачання через головні газопроводи
різко зменшилося.
Також це вплинуло й на ціни:
не менш різко, але в інший бік - до зростання.
Постачальники енергії просять про допомогу.
Нам необхідне дуже швидке рішення,
також і від міністерства,
що робити із підвищеними цінами.
Це означає, що споживачам
також доведеться пристосуватися.
Ми очікуємо, що вже цього року
домогосподарствам доведеться платити
додатково в середньому 1000-2000 євро.
Зараз газосховища Німеччини заповнені на 58% -
цього занадто мало для зими.
Опозиція скаржиться на те,
що оголошення надзвичайної ситуації стане шоком.
Шок був би меншим,
якби план розробили заздалегідь.
План, до якого ми вже кілька тижнів
закликаємо тут, у Бундестазі.
Будь ласка, будьте готовими до того,
що може статися.
Ми докладаємо максимальних зусиль,
щоб все вдалося.
Пане Шпан, я не знаю, чи Ви це помітили,
але це і є частина нашого плану.
Вивести країну з кризи,
у яку Ви її завели!
Для промисловості та споживачів:
скільки енергії не вистачатиме взимку - наразі точно невідомо.
З нами на зв'язку Франк Бетман.
Франку, багато хто стурбований тим,
чи означатиме «режим тривоги»,
що ціна для споживачів стане ще вищою?
У будь-якому випадку буде значно дорожче,
але коли саме?
Через «режим тривоги» встановлюють,
коли підвищені закупівельні ціни
можуть бути перекладені далі, тобто на споживачів.
З остаточним розрахунком під кінець року
чи раніше, як авансовий платіж.
Нещодавно прийняті зміни до Закону про енергобезпеку
покликані принаймні зараз захистити споживачів,
адже негайне підвищення цін прив'язується до певних умов.
Федеральна мережева агенція BNetzA
повинна констатувати факт
значного скорочення обсягів імпорту газу.
Оскільки цього ще не зроблено,
постачальники не мають права передавати підвищені ціни споживачам.
Але якщо BNetzA визнає, що імпорт газу значно скоротився,
ситуація зміниться і високі ціни на газ
перекладатимуть прямо на споживачів.
Наприклад, Амстердам вже підвищив
європейську референтну ціну на газ на 4%.
В будь-кому разі усім потрібно готуватися
до подальшого зростання ціни на газ.
Дякую, Франку.
27 разів «так» для України та Республіки Молдови
щодо отримання статусу кандидата на членство в ЄС.
За це обставав канцлер Шольц на сьогоднішньому саміті ЄС.
І є багато ознак того, що все спрацює.
А як щодо 6 країн Західних Балкан,
які вже дуже довго чекають?
З одного боку, вони не миряться одна з одною,
з іншого - усі вони розчаровані швидкістю,
з якою Україна, здається,
набуває статусу країни-кандидата ЄС.
Засідання ЄС щодо Західних Балкан
сьогодні завершилися безрезультатно.
Інна Донт.
Теплі вітання після перших зустрічей на саміті,
бо посеред кризи врешті є що відсвяткувати:
очевидно, Україна отримає статус кандидата.
Оскільки це передусім сигнал солідарності,
ніхто не може висловитися проти.
Це важливо, що ми в Європі діємо разом.
За останні кілька днів і тижнів
я вів активні розмови з багатьма.
Ідилія на «сімейному фото»
із 6 країнами Західних Балкан радше не справжня, а зіграна.
Ці країни гостро дискутували з ЄС.
Кожен крок на шляху до членства в ЄС
повинен бути одноголосно затверджений
усіма 27 країнами ЄС.
Але завжди знаходиться принаймні одна країна,
яка накладає вето.
Тому переговори із Сербією тривають вже 8 років -
із Чорногорією - 10 років.
Албанія та Північна Македонія чекають вічність,
щоб нарешті почати свої перемовини.
Обидві країни розглядаються в одному пакеті.
Але початок переговорів з Північною Македонією
блокує Болгарія,
хоча вони обидві вже тривалий час разом в НАТО.
Болгарія блокує дві інші країни НАТО -
Албанію і Північну Македонію -
на тлі гарячої війни в Європі.
Інші 26 країн ЄС
влаштували «жахливе шоу неспроможності».
В очікуванні статусу кандидата знаходяться
Боснія-Герцеговина і Косово,
які хотіли б насолоджуватися принаймні безвізовим режимом.
Ми виконали всі вимоги,
і тепер настав час країнам-членам підтримати цей процес.
Це велика несправедливість щодо народу Косова.
Звинувачення і ніякого прогресу
для країн Західних Балкан.
Але Україна і Республіка Молдова, ймовірно,
отримають статус кандидата,
на що вони так сильно сподіваються.
Анна Геллінек у Брюсселі.
Статус кандидата -
важкі рішення для Брюсселю.
«Так/ні» Західним Балканам і, мабуть, «так» Україні.
Що це за сигнал?
Під час дискусій щодо розширення ЄС
можна побачити два обличчя ЄС.
У випадку українців, в умовах війни,
ЄС може прийняти це символічне рішення,
яке маркує також політичний курс,
і надати Україні статус кандидата.
У випадку із Західними Балканами
криза лише здається незначною,
але всі механізми,
які сповільнюють прийняття до ЄС, в дії.
Вето від 1-єї країни, неодностайність серед країн-членів,
немає лідерів, які могли б вирішити проблемні питання.
Сьогодні 27 лідерів хочуть надати Україні
статус кандидата
і називають це історичним кроком.
Однак слід зазначити, що залишити Західні Балкани
в очікуванні, буде історичною помилкою.
Дякую, Анно.
Після поставок зброї з Німеччини
Україна отримала важке озброєння також і від США,
але, можливо вже запізно,
аби зупинити просування
російських військ на Сході.
За даними українського Генштабу
противник захоплює нові території.
Детальніше - Антуан Куршільген.
* постріли *
Російські ракетні установки обстрілюють українські позиції.
Стверджують, що в Луганській області російська армія
захопила ще три населені пункти,
у тому числі стратегічно важливе село Тошківка.
Інші захоплені території
знаходяться поруч з  Лисичанськом.
Місто все ще під контролем України,
але російська армія наближається до того,
щоб оточити Лисичанськ.
Тоді постачання для українських військ
буде заблоковане.
До війни тут проживало 100 тис. людей.
Більшість евакуювалася,
близько 7 тис. людей все ще залишається тут.
Волонтери допомагають вивезти їх у безпечне місце.
Час спливає.
Скоро тут будуть вуличні бої,
можливо, вони триватимуть місяцями.
Цих людей потрібно вивезти звідси,
оскільки багато хто може загинути
або вони житимуть у жахливих умовах.
Під важкими обстрілами також портове місто Миколаїв,
що на півдні України.
Тут розбомбили підприємство,
яке виробляло рослинну олію.
Москва опублікувала сьогодні це відео:
постачання для фронту залізницею.
Ці кадри мають нести послання:
наступ на Сході України триває.
Верховний суд США класифікує носіння зброї
в громадських місцях як «базове право»,
таким чином скасовуючи закон штату Нью-Йорк.
Відповідно до останнього,
особа мала підтвердити особливу потребу
носити із собою зброю.
Впливове збройове лобі NRA
відзначило це рішення як «перемогу»,
президент США Байден глибоко розчарований.
До руйнівного землетрусу
в Афганістані.
Країна, життя в якій і до цього було нелегким,
зокрема через посухи та голод.
За даними Організації гуманітарної допомоги Welthungerhilfe
20 млн афганців не знають,
чи зможуть отримати достатньо харчування.
Ситуація після землетрусу важка,
бракує інформації щодо дійсного стану справ.
Різні організації допомоги,
також і з Німеччини,
намагаються потрапити до
важкодоступної зони лиха.
ООН говорить про 770 загиблих,
але їхня кількість ще може значно зрости.
Детальніше - Йорг Бразе.
Волонтери і наша команда ZDF
намагаються потрапити в гори до зруйнованих сіл.
Під колесами машин - болото,
це значно сповільнює рух.
З цих кадрів зрозуміло, наскільки складно
доставити допомогу у віддалені регіони.
Прибувши, бачимо усю картину руйнувань.
Ті, хто вижили, досі перебувають в шоковому стані.
Там був наш будинок.
А поряд -
релігійна школа для дівчат.
Лише одна дитина і одна доросла особа вижили.
Усі інші загинули.
Готуються до поховання загиблих.
Серед них - багато жінок і дітей.
Зі сльозами на очах люди прощаються зі своїми рідними.
Майже в кожній родині є жертви.
На щастя, у моїй родині ніхто не загинув.
Але в сім'ї мого брата загинуло 36 людей,
які були дуже близькі для мене.
У лікарні провінції Пактика багато поранених.
Місцеві лікарні перевантажені.
Щоб доправити пацієнтів до лікарень в інші райони,
потрібно багато машин швидкої допомоги, яких нам бракує.
Ми постійно зіштовхуємося з такими труднощами.
Вони ховають своїх рідних у
братських могилах
і чекають допомоги, яка так потрібна,
щоб пережити холодні ночі і
відбудувати будинки.
Але, очевидно, доведеться довго чекати,
доки допомога надійде і сюди, у гори.
Якщо Ви бажаєте допомогти жителям Афганістану,
реквізити рахунку для пожертвувань на екрані:
Призначення: ZDF, екстрена допомога Афганістану.
Детальніша інформація на spenden.zdf.de
і в текстовій версії ZDF на сторінці 890.
У найгустонаселенішій землі Північний Рейн-Вестфалія,
очевидно, вперше буде сформовано чорно-зелений уряд.
CDU і Зелені погодили коаліційну угоду.
Прем’єрміністр Гендрік Вюст заявив, що
обидві сторони мають спільні погляди щодо
посилення заходів із захисту клімату,
інвестицій в освіту та інфраструктуру.
Лідерка Зелених у федеральній землі Мона Нойбаур
наголосила на прагненні зробити
Північний Рейн-Вестфалію
першим кліматично нейтральним
промисловим регіоном в Європі.
Цими вихідними коаліційна угода
має бути схвалена на з’їздах обох партій.
З початку зимового семестру
учні, практиканти та студенти зможуть отримати
більшу стипендію від держави (Bafög),
яка передбачає повернення частини коштів державі вже під час роботи.
Бундестаг схвалив
підвищення державної підтримки на навчання.
Також розширять коло претендентів
на стипендію.
Кількість отримувачів Bafög знижувалася роками.
У 2012 році отримувачів стипендії було 980 000,
а в 2020 році їх нараховувалося менше 640 тис.,
тобто на 35% менше.
Зараз - спроба змінити тенденцію.
Детальніше - Андреас Лінке.
Ханна Гуткнехт навчається
в Університеті медіа в Штутгарті,
займається активною діяльністю
в молодіжному крилі партії Зелених.
Ханна досі живе з батьками.
Житло в Штутгарті дороге.
Ціни зростають і надалі,
все ускладнюється.
Звісно, в мене є мета - орендувати житло,
але тут же з'являється думка,
чи вистачить мені коштів?
У однокурсників Ханни
фінансове становище ще скрутніше.
Я змушена дуже економити.
Я дуже рідко відвідую клуби чи кафе,
інколи кожного дня їм макарони, бо це дешево.
Уряд Німеччини прагне сприяти тим, хто навчається.
Такі наміри озвучила у Бундестазі
міністерка освіти Штарк-Ватцінгер,
яка хоче полегшити студентам
вибір власної освітньої траєкторії.
Надто багато тих, хто навчається, опинився поза увагою
і не отримував допомогу.
Ми змінюємо цю тенденцію.
Більше стипендій BAföG означає більше свободи.
Основні новації щодо BAföG:
у майбутньому студенти
зможуть отримати до 934 євро
замість 861, з часткою позики,
яку в подальшому потрібно повернути державі.
Також підвищили межу доходу батьків,
з якої можливо претендувати на стипендію:
з 2000 до 2415 євро.
Студентські організації вимагають
ще більшої відповідності рішень влади
реальному життю, наприклад,
збільшення максимального періоду отримання стипендії:
стандартний термін навчання плюс два семестри,
адже саме стільки часу триває навчання у більшості.
До того ж потрібно полегшити зміну спеціальності під час навчання,
якщо у студента виникне таке бажання чи необхідність.
BAföG не потрібно прив'язувати лише до доходів батьків,
ця стипендія має стати тим,
чим була на початку, а саме
повноцінною субсидією, аби студенти не боялися боргів,
які можуть виникнути за неможливості
повернення частини стипендії, як вимагається зараз,
аби такі студенти як Ханна Гуткнехт
жили трохи спокійніше
і працювали для свого кращого майбутнього.
Знову страйк  у великих портах Німеччини
- цього разу він тривав 24 години.
Тисячі мітингарів пройшлися Гамбургом.
Вони вимагають підвищення погодинної оплати праці
на 1,20 євро
і збільшення щорічних надбавок за певні види роботи.
Четвертий раунд переговорів з роботодавцями
завершився безрезультатно.
Ймовірно, страйк уповільнить і без того
запізнілі відправки і отримання товарів.
Міністр охорони здоров'я Лаутербах
попереджає про серйозну хвилю коронавірусу восени.
Разом зі своїми колегами з федеральних земель
Лаутербах планує оголосити заходи на цей час.
Інститут Роберта Коха RKI зареєстрував
119 360 нових випадків коронавірусу за день, що
на 30 218 більше, ніж тиждень тому.
Неофіційні дані, ймовірно, набагато вищі.
За 24 години у зв'язку з вірусом
померло 98 осіб.
Вперше з середини травня показник захворюваності
становить понад 500.
Ми переходимо до новин спорту.
Сьогодні у Берліні розпочались змагання Finals.
190 титулів у 14 видах спорту
лише за 4 дні в одному місті -
дуже особлива мультиспортивна подія.
Перший титул чемпіона було
здобуто в абсолютно новому виді спорту -
швидкісному канополо.
Чотири проти чотирьох
на річці Шпреє біля East Side Gallery.
Берлінський клуб K.S.V. Havelbrüder
переміг у фіналі
проти команди Rothe Mühle Essen з рахунком 7:3.
Швидкий та цікавий вид спорт тепер має
першого чемпіона Німеччини!
Сім кілометрів на північ у районі Пренцлауер-Берґ
у палаці спорту імені Макса Шмелінга
Леоні Адам також досягла перемоги.
Нова чемпіонка Німеччини зі стрибків на батуті
показала найкраще виконання
гвинтів та сальто.
29-річна спортсменка виграє вже свій п'ятий титул.
Лена Мейснер затвердила чемпіонство
команди з Бушхютена
у змішаній естафеті з триатлону.
На Олімпійському стадіоні команда
підтвердила свій успіх
на спринтерській дистанції
між Потсдамом і Берліном.
Ви можете переглянути змагання
завтра у прямому ефірі на zdf з 13 години.
На тенісному турнірі WTA у Бад-Гомбурзі
дві останні німецькі тенісистки
програли представницям Франції.
Спочатку Сабіна Лісіцкі
програла у чвертьфіналі Каролін Гарсія.
Після цього Анжеліка Кербер отримала поразку
у матчі проти Алізе Корне.
Мартін Хінтереггер несподівано завершив
свою професійну футбольну карʼєру.
Це стало наслідком ділових стосунків
29-річного захисника команди Айнтрахт Франкфурт
із правопопулістським політиком.
Через кілька тижнів після перемоги в Лізі Європи
команду з Франкфурта залишає багаторічний
гравець австрійської збірної.
Ліга чемпіонів тут, у Франкфурті!
Запланований ним, любительський турнір у Каринтії
та нещодавно викриті контакти із
правопопулістським політиком
Гайнріхом Сіклом з Австрійської партії свободи FPÖ
послугували причиною для виходу
футболіста із клубу.
У повідомленні про завершення карʼєри
на сайті клубу
Хінтереггер відсторонився від нетолерантних заяв.
Його контакт з Айнтрахтом, що був дійсний
ще два роки,
був розірвано.
Він був культовим гравцем.
Так, дуже несподівана новина.
Дякую, Норберте!
Сьогодні вночі та вранці очікуються грози.
Наскільки вони будуть сильними
та які регіони оминуть,
далі розповість Катя Хорнеффер.
Інтерв'ю Міністра економіки Габека
сьогодні в ефірі heute journal.
з Марієттою Сломкою о 21:45.
Дякую, гарного вечора і
залишайтесь із нами на ZDF.
Добрий вечір.
Вже сьогодні вранці були
перші сильні грози
у південній Франції.
Тут утворився грозовий циклон,
який зараз рухається до Німеччини.
Вночі він пройде від
Баден-Вюртембергу до Баварії
і буде відчутним також у
Рейнланд-Пфальці та Саарі.
У Північному Рейні-Вестфалії і
на заході Нижньої Саксонії
також треба готуватись до сильної грози,
зливи, граду та поривів вітру.
На сході погода вночі буде ясною,
температура знизиться до 13-15°.
Через парке грозове повітря
температура буде вищою - 15-19°.
Завтра також парко,
температура сягне 21-16°.
На північному сході температура
підніметься до 28-33°.
Між гірським регіоном Ерцґебірґе та Балтійським морем
переважно ясно.
Сильні грози та зливи
очікуються у другій половині дня.
У суботу погода стабілізується,
грози можливі лише на північному сході.
Температура 23-29°.
У неділю із заходу приходять нові зливи та грози.
На сході стає дуже спекотно
Чудового вечора.